there's this guy Charlemagne the God I
can't keep calling him that whatever his
real name is I don't think he's a real
God but he's a guy on he's got a Comedy
Central show we've played some clips of
him before uh certainly not a concern
you know he's a lefty basically but so I
would guess some sort of like
disgruntled Lefty something like that uh
he had his paddle on on Comedy Central
uh talking about what's going on here
with DeSantis and the Democrats
the Republican Governors have sent
bustle illegal immigrants to Sanctuary
cities like New York DC and Chicago with
the message of if you liked him so much
they're yours okay well just in time for
Hispanic Heritage Month Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis upped the game by sending
two playing folds of immigrants to the
east coast Elites favorite vacation
island Martha's Vineyard Massachusetts I
personally think it's genius
but I wish that government is like Ron
DeSantis and Greg Abbott would give
Democratic Governors and Mayors more of
a heads up because then that would
expose the hypocrisy of the Democrats
which is they don't want immigrants here
either all right so I honestly don't
know who those panelists were but like
you know I know how hard people work if
you're if you're in the biz like I know
how hard people work to get to be a
panelist on a show or to get a show or
you know to sit there and have someone
put makeup on you and sit in front of
the lights and have people applaud for
you and everything else look to get all
the way there
I meant to be so miserable while you're
there it's just it's just the perfect
end result of leftist thinking so
Charlemagne basically gets it he says
this thing's kind of good because it's
exposing that the Democrats don't
believe any of the nonsense they're kind
of spewing now I he probably still
thinks DeSantis is racist or a bunch of
other bad stuff so I'm not making this
that that he fully gets it but the way
they just sit there and they have they
have really nothing to say because the
Democrats don't care about illegals the
Democrats if the Democrats cared about
illegals you would be for a strong
border everyone that is here in this
country if you look back at your lineage
right virtually everyone that is here
their families came here and hopefully
came legally with nothing made a better
life their kids are better off the
grandkids are better off Etc et cetera
and that still is possible
um but if you are just for allowing
anyone to come in do whatever they want
bring whatever culture they want
whatever all of the stuff all of the
crime that comes with it and then be on
the the Dole of the system while your
main driver of your political ethos is
that the system is evil at the exact
same time that is a recipe to destroy a
country so I don't know how you can
frame this in any other way than the
people that are really in charge on the
Democrat side want to destroy the
country and actually the rest of Biden's
policies in terms of energy and
everything else would kind of indicate
that but the point of showing you that
clip and I don't know who's watching
comedy central anymore is that there is
a little bit of it bubbling up right
that's a little bit bubbling up into
corporate Comedy Central is just
corporate Viacom programming and what
they're showing you on there is the
santis isn't pure evil maybe he wasn't
fully there on that but the the
Democrats do suck on illegal immigration
because they don't care